[Musique]
c'est bientôt la fête des amoureux veut
tous les amoureux les amoureux vont se
retrouver pour des petits plats psg
commence à perdre mes notes à bien se
passer tous les amoureux et amoureuses
vont se retrouver pour s'offrir des
cadeaux dans un premier temps et puis
après ils font ce qu'ils veulent ça les
regarde cesser leur intimité ça ne me
regarde pas par contre moi je me suis
dit ok pour la saint-valentin pourquoi
est-ce que je vous présenterai pas des
produits tech spécialement dédié pour
les amoureux les amoureux il y en a pour
toutes les bourses y en a pour tous les
goûts il y en a pour les familles là
pour les hommes il ya de tout dont 4
kwassa plaisir vous avez dit élection
tech tout est noté là dedans pour les
petites notes de trouver 10 produits que
je trouve couleurs le tout premier
produit sont un produit made in france
pour sa part des français s'appelle
allofs doctorale aux boks je voulais
montrer dans une vidéo il ya des deux
ans l'idée en fait c'est que c'est une
petite boîte une petite boîte d'amour
avec un coeur dessus vous vous avez une
application votre amoureux votre
amoureuse peu importe de son côté à
cette petite boîte depuis votre
smartphone vous lui envoyer un petit
message d'amour quand le message arrive
et bien le car qui a fait à tourner sur
l'âme sans la jolie petite boîte on nous
et on lit le message à l'intérieur alors
ça c'est rigolo ça sert pas forcément
tout le temps dans tout cas sur des
périodes de saint valentin en mai
d'envoyer de l'amour très facilement
vous êtes au bureau vous avez le club
boxe devant vous la personne voit
message tac tac tac vous ouvrirez votre
message c'est beau c'est l'amour c'est
la saint valentin c'est le premier cas
nous l'avions d'ailleurs tout c'est un
produit je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description et puis tant que j'y
pense vous invite à me mettre un petit
pouce vers le haut sur cette vidéo vous
savez algorithmes eux faisant il faut
des pouces c'est comme ça que ça marche
donc si vous pouvez le faire
nous avons encore plus d'amour ça c'est
la saint-valentin double triple saint
valentin c'est génial bon ensuite je
pensais qu'un truc qui prennent
vachement cool c'est une mode connecté
alors c'est peut-être moins un côté un
peu love love petits coeurs et
paillettes dans les yeux mais néanmoins
ça fait toujours plaisir lorsque votre
amoureux votre amoureuse vous offre une
jolie montre pour pouvoir avoir toutes
vos informations et recevoir ses
messages outils sms d'amour vous lui
enverrai directement pour les jours
suivants parce que vous lui offrez le
jour de la saint-valentin sapin game
assez logique si vous n'êtes plus dans
l'écosystème apple bien évidemment
l'apels watch vraiment exceptionnel très
très beaux produits
donc ça ça me paraît vraiment cool et
puis si vous êtes dans le côté plus
android ya deux mondes qui sont failli à
plusieurs mondes cool moi il y en a une
que j'aime bien c'est la galaxie ou
attractive
à 4-2 qui vachement cool parce que tout
autour du cadran peuvent naviguer avec
votre doigt il ya un côté vraiment sympa
l'os est vraiment cool expérience
globale et super d'ailleurs si vous la
connaissez pas vous invite à aller voir
mon test pour la découvrir modèles
masculins modèle féminin est vraiment
bien il ya d'être connecté que j'aime
aussi beaucoup c'est la faux cils de
cinquième génération vous pouvez venir
paramétrer l'autonomie important que
vous allez activer/désactiver c'est
vraiment vraiment cool prendre vraiment
la main dessus donc ça je vous invite à
les découvrir si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas mais je pense que c'est vraiment des
canaux qui sont chouettes c'est un bel
objet vous pouvez communiquer avec votre
amoureux votre amoureuse gaza c'est donc
là non pour moi ça s'inscrit dans
l'amour incertain donc ça c'est vraiment
cool hunting troisième produit
c'est ça la google next up alors google
les stops je sais pas si vous connaissez
comme google laisse cette enceinte où
vous venez parler sur ce que là vous
rajouter de la fonction vidéo dont vous
pouvez venir parler à google assistant
qui vous trouvera tout ce que vous
voulez vous recueil votre métier votre
argent et compagnie mais ce qui est
super alors moi j'en ai 2 g celui là que
j'ai utilisé pendant longtemps et c'est
le même axe que j'utilise à la maison et
ce qui est vraiment génial avec ce
produit
c'est qu'en fait ça vous fait revivre
vos souvenirs lorsque vous allez le
paramétrer vous allez choisir ce que
vous allez vouloir afficher comme photo
photo bien évidemment vous avez déjà
fait avec votre amoureux votre amoureuse
moi c'est vachement bien et vous pouvez
dire ok moi ce que j'ai fait par contre
à la maison j'ai sélectionné le visage
de mon amoureuse le visage de mon fils
et ce sont leurs images qui apparaissent
celle-là au studio c'est pareil et bien
ça ne fait apparaître les photos
d'elliot les photos de justin
donc je peux les voir quand je ne sont
pas avec moi ça permet de revivre un peu
le côté un mort ça c'est bien en termes
d'assistance à la maison pour premiers
kills facilement et puis pour être
toujours avec votre amoureux ou votre
amoureuse ça c'est vraiment cool mais
c'est vraiment super produit qui rend
plein plein plein plein de bons services
charlotte qui les lie vraiment amoureux
ou amoureuse j'ai présenté il ya
quelques jours les freebox 3 de huawei
sont des petits écouteurs pour venir
écouter votre musique mais je voulais
ressort vous allez voir vous pouvez les
emmener partout avec vous vous avez vos
petits freebug vous les prenez vous les
posez dans vos oreilles ça marche ça
tracé millions et bien croyez-le ou non
ou à quoi nous a sorti un petit modèle
qui pour moi est vraiment saint valentin
se sont pareils des freebets 3 sauf que
cette fois ci ils sont rouges donc
sweety sosa valentin ça c'est la couleur
de l'amour par rapport aux blancs alors
bon les deux sont rigolos ils peuvent
faire des petits trucs comme ça c'est
strictement ridicule donc ça c'est bien
vous le prenez vous l'ouvrez vous le
sortez c'est quand même vachement plus
mignon couleur de l'amour à vos oreilles
vous pouvez offrir ça à votre valentin
ou valentine une fois de plus il se
produit vous intéresse vous ai mis à
lire dans la description rien d'autres
produits que j'ai découvert que je
connaissais pas qui ça va changer de
couleur dans cette vidéo c'est en fait
un petit tracteur d'activité que vous
allez pouvoir à travers les activités
vous connaissez les montres vous à
d'essayer ça mais sous forme de bijoux
vous pouvez la voir en bracelet vous
pouvez la voir en collier ce appris
qu'elle trouve assez joli je n'ai pas
testé un nom que je peux pas vous donner
morton mais pour offrir un côté bijoux
connectés tech le produit assez original
je trouve jolie ils rendraient service
dont ça c'est cool qui dit produits tech
qui dit on a dit aussi protection contre
les ondes et justement vous avez un
caleçon qui vient vous protéger contre
les ondes et qui vient protéger vos
parties intimes comme ça assez rigolo
comme on est sur nos smartphones dans la
poche
il faut penser aussi à protéger nos
partis pour éviter trop les irradiés
dans quelle mesure ça vient vraiment
protégé dans quelle mesure on est
vraiment et radio je sais pas en tout
cas cadeaux rigolo principe de
précaution surtout saint valentin
faisant c'est un truc assez originale
aux canaux que je trouve vraiment cool
c'est le côté miroir connectés alors
c'est moi le truc qu'on va s'offrir
tenir à la main se mettre en bague
autour de couches comme ça mais si vous
aimez la tech et bien le fait d'offrir
un miroir qualité de c'est vraiment cool
parce que ça me permettra effectivement
d'avoir pleins d'applications déjà avoir
la météo votre agenda pouvoir regarder
des vidéos sur youtube un petit tuto de
noeud de cravate ou un petit tuto pour
le maquillage en même temps vous et vos
tutoz vous mettiez vous avez la force
assure ça vraiment bien c'est pratique
c'est utile c'est bien c'est un vrai
sens à la maison et en plus ça coûte et
anti-buée que demande le peuple
cheuvreux qui dit saint valentin dit
jolie soirée en amoureux dit jolie
éclairage alors justement je fais un
truc qui est vachement bien pour
l'éclairage c'est un you go your world
philips ses salles à cette jolie petite
chose là vous pouvez changer la couleur
moi je les mets dans cette couleur là
ici en ambulance ou global mais je
trouve ça assez rigolo parce que en fait
ce que j'aime bien regarder parce que
demain puis derrière il n'y a changé la
couleur vous pouvez faire depuis votre
application alors il vous faut un pont
où il vous faut un système philips sa
change comme ça là ça fait un peu peur
qu'on était un mode halloween mode
amoureux comme ça il y a un côté très
luminothérapie woods paramétrer comme
vous voulez il vous faut un pont ou à la
maison au minimum pour pouvoir connecter
vous avez l'application philip sion pour
piloter depuis votre smartphone vous
avez différents accessoires des petits
boutons des interrupteurs pour le
paramétrer vous ai déjà parlé de philips
ou d'ailleurs vous invite à y voir la
vidéo c'est pas déjà comme ça vous
saurez tout mais ce petit truc là je
trouve bien parce que vous pouvez
brancher il est indépendant vous le
posez sur un jeu fait vous le mettez sur
un bureau
ça vous fait une petite larme ça vous
fait un petit point lumineux je trouve
ça vraiment vraiment bien et puis
soutient son sweat il pouvait mettre un
petit du couleur rouge version amour
alors je devienne notre truc que je
trouvais très très rigolo que j'avais
déjà vu déjà par le passé ce genre de
genre de choses c'est un robot
cosmétiques c'est à dire que si vous
aimez vous maquiller ou si votre
conjoint conjointe m se maquiller et
bien vous avez en robot cosmétiques pour
fabriquer soi-même sa cosmétiques
il ya un côté éco responsable il ya un
côté du mythe yourself c'est assez
marrant vous mettez ce que vous et
faites ce que vous voulez vous pouvez
fabriquer du shampoing du dentifrice de
la crème hydratante du rouge à lèvres
votre des eaux enfin il ya pas mal de
possibilités sous ça marrant et ça c'est
un cadeau qui est aussi relativement
atypique dernier cadeau que je trouve
vraiment cool et justine si tu regarde
je veux bien que tu me l'offre un sacré
plaisir ne suis pas sûr mais si jamais
je le variés pour la saint valentin
je saurai d'où ça vient ça s'appelle
mike reno en fait c'est un petit kit
d'oenologie
c'est un petit capteur vous aller
tremper dans votre vin qui est lié à une
application sur votre smartphone et qui
va vous donner toutes les informations
sur le vin ça vous donnera sa
composition tannique patamix issa et
compagnie vous saurez tout sur votre
ventre vous aurez plein d'informations
ça vous aidera effectivement là lorsque
vous allez déguster ce permettra
effectivement de voir réellement ce qui
aurait donc permettre vous si vous êtes
un petit peu avertis et bien vous pouvez
venir chercher la composition du vin
avec votre nez et avec votre palais et
ensuite voir dans l'application ce qui
vous dit il ya pas mal de choses à faire
avec son ca assez rigolo si vous aimez
le vent c'est pourquoi c'est un super
cadeau à faire
son valentin ou à sa valentine voilà
pour ces dix plateaux teck lee à la
saint valentin ça c'est un peu les idées
que j'ai trouvé essayer de choper un peu
à droite à gauche entre des produits que
j'ai des produits j'ai cherché sur
internet
a vous de me dire vous quel est votre
sélection et la saint-valentin marqué le
mois en bas aux commandes qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez avoir pour la saint
valentin
qu'est ce que vous allez offrir qu'est
ce que vous allez recevoir qu'est ce que
vous avez eu l'année dernière est ce
qu'il ya des cadeaux qui vous ont plu
pas plus est ce qu a dit qu'à d'autres
tech que j'ai oublié que vous pourriez
vous aussi marqué en bas vous invite à
me démarquer comme ça j'en viendrais
puis ça peut donner des idées aussi à
offrir à ma valentine sur ce je vous
embrasse vous donne rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer à parler tech
parce que croyez moi il ya plein de
choses à dire on en voit l'amour
forcément saint valentin des coeurs en
amour à demain
[Musique]
l avion